good morning everyone and is that on yet
okay good a good morning everyone and
thanks for joining me this morning one
of the great things about this
conference is there's a lot of people
talking about code about tools about
things they've done experiments they've
run research they've done I'm not going
to be talking about any of those things
I'm going to talk a little bit about
some per seat some issues that I
perceive in the community and things
that I hope we can foster some
conversation around and perhaps do
something about regarding privacy
research data and at our community first
a little bit about our organization as
mentioned we're a nonprofit organization
where a membership-based organization
we're based up in Baltimore we develop
things for the publishing library and
software communities things you might be
familiar with the ISBN number on the
back of books issn numbers dublin core
metadata we also do things like
education of and i just highlight this
we just published just yesterday
research data primer for early career
professionals I'm sure most of you in
this room art won't be needing it but
maybe people on your staff new to the
community who are interested in these
sort of issues and we have our author
here hi Carly thank you so very quickly
just a little bit of context in 2010
this nice gentleman who i'm sure you all
are aware of said something along the
lines of if he were creating facebook in
2010 he would have said all of the
privacy policies to be open as default
and a lot of people took this to say
that the age of privacy is over that's
not exactly what he said but i think the
notion of privacy norms sort of changed
and facebook is pushing us in that
direction but really have they may
people really do care about privacy and
this is just one example of a research
study this
earlier this year from the Pew stating
at about ninety three percent of people
are really interested in privacy some
eighty-seven percent don't want to be
tracked online want to have some control
of their privacy and yet we have things
like fitbit's and i phone tracking and
I'm I use map my run tracking my run
this morning so we're all generating
tremendous amount of data that is
exceptionally useful in the community
and you know a lot of what we've been
talking about here at this meeting has
been associated with that so we're in a
bit of a conundrum I think the fact that
2014 was sort of defined as the year of
the breach I mean how many of us had to
find a new credit card because our data
was stolen by target orts or released
from Target or a variety of other
providers I don't want to go too far
afield here but there is an core there
is a association between privacy and
security but not all issues of privacy
are hacks not all breaches are
necessarily malicious and not all data
sharing is inappropriate and where do we
find that fine line between what is
appropriate what is useful and and what
we can do with the data we're generating
many of us use google analytics for our
websites I mean this is one example of
how we are leaching information about
the behavior of people who use our
systems to the community in ways that we
don't necessarily know or or really
understand what's going on behind the
scenes another privacy related issue
came up just last year in the library
community where Adobe which is using
this something called Adobe Digital
Editions which is a digital rights
management software was transmitting
information back to Adobe's digital
central servers it was doing so in an
unencrypted manner so that anyone could
sniff out exactly what was in someone
say library on their can
puter I don't think this was necessarily
malicious on Adobe's part I think it
just goes to show how privacy isn't
necessarily at the top of minds of
organizations that are creating the
software that we're using in our
day-to-day lives so kind of switching
back gears a little as I mentioned we
work with the primarily with the library
and publishing communities we often
envision in the libraries looking
something like this but in fact many
libraries these days look more like this
the invitee infrastructure for the
library is often one of the most
intensive areas in the in an academic
institution to create and share
information and a lot of library
information is now provided not by the
library it's provided in the cloud via
via service providers the content that
you go when you access something online
isn't actually in the library it's
hosted by the publisher site the
discovery services are hosted by third
parties so increasingly what the library
community is providing to the community
to the patrons is actually not managed
by the library and this runs into
something one of the core principles of
the library community the library
community since the 1930s has had this
as part of their code of ethics about
the commitment that the library
community has to intellectual freedom
and the right of privacy for people who
are accessing library services this was
a response to World War one where people
were actually jailed for their library
search behaviors and ever since then the
library community has actually been very
strong proponents of intellectual
freedom in a way that most of the rest
of the community doesn't really
recognize but they've been staunch
advocates for privacy and how this
relates to our community this
conversation data repositories are
generally not libraries not all data
scientists are librarians
they don't have this background and be a
kind of grounding and it's a little
intellectual freedom one approach to
privacy is i'm going to use as an
example the internet archive i don't
know how many top 10 i think top 20 web
sites on the web erase their server logs
so that they protect the patron the user
privacy i think they stand out in this
regard but i think that's sort of an
absolutist approach and i don't think
it's going to be really useful i mean if
we are here talking about data data
science what information we can glean
from data erasing the data every night
is not a good idea so where is there a
happy medium in there related to what we
can do with research data but also
simultaneously address some of the
privacy concerns because ideally we want
people to continue to contribute data in
a way that we can continue to use it so
I'd like to think of things and this may
be as scientific as I'm going to get in
this presentation we have vectors that
are related to privacy that are specific
to research data and some of the issues
around this that I perceive that are
challenging for our community the first
is data sets that actually contain
personally identifiable information much
of what we're talking about here is
either medical data sociological data
economic data business information all
of the men much of that data around that
is involves human subjects so much of
even data that is notionally devoid of
personally identifiable information can
point to personally identifiable
information latina Sweeney in two
thousand showed that eighty-seven
percent of Americans can be identified
by three data points
zip code sex and come on screw birthday
three data points yesterday in his talk
was Peter Cetera yesterday made a point
about cookies and how in his community
they've identified something like three
million potential data points from
cookies and how they can identify
whether or not it's my eight-year-old
son who's browsing the web rather than
me and while it might not contain
personally identifiable information if
they can calculate that it's my
eight-year-old son browsing the web and
not me they can pretty much guarantee I
guarantee that they could use that
processing power to identify me
personally using I don't know my
operating system my battery and the IP
address where I'm gaining my my access
so we have to think broadly about
personally identifiable information what
counts as personally identifiable
information that is included in that
data there are issues with an anonymous
ation you can strip away all of the
personally identifiable information out
of a data set but then how valuable is
that data set what's the where's the
spine line here between removing all of
the useful information from a set of
data and still having a useful set of
data I'm not going to get into any of
the technical issues there are many and
we're going to be talking on the next
speaker in the next session next plenary
session is going to be talking about
anonymization in more detail and more
technical detail but really what's what
are what's the balance there
another issue and vector here that I
think is important is we want to share
data and we want to merge data so that
we can draw novel conclusions from that
merge data sets you might strip out
personally identifiable information from
one data set and you might have another
data set that doesn't have personally
identifiable information but when you
combine them you might expose personally
identifiable information by combining
multiple data sets and pulling together
different different data stores you
could triangulate to personally
identifiable information another vector
that I think is important is say you
have a data set that is historical in
nature and you presume that everyone in
it is dead a great example of this is
there's a cycle a mental health facility
that was closed in the 1920s and some of
the researchers want to do some data
data mining on that on that data store
and you presume that everyone who was
there from the 1920s is no longer with
us but say if you combine that mental
health data with something like ancestry
com data some genealogical data store
you could then historically track back
to people who are live today and say
there is some potentially some
genealogical or genetic link to mental
health disorders well your
great-great-great grandfather was here
in this mental health facility had
congratulations you have a fifty percent
chance of getting Alzheimer's so we're
not going to ensure you anymore I mean
these are the sort of issues when you're
combining multiple data stores and
dealing with personally sensitive
information
another issue and something that I don't
think is discussed much at least in this
context is the issue of the data that's
being generated by the use of these
systems Internet systems are all
tracking behavior all the time we've got
log files about who's using those
systems if you know enough about a field
and you are track and you are looking at
who is gathering information and using
say heart medical data from multiple
different sources and you can see the IP
range and say well that person is coming
from Harvard Medical School I bet that's
probably professor so and so and if
they're looking at this and this and
this if you know enough about the field
you could maybe discern what their
research is maybe jump ahead of them
maybe patent their technology before
they do who is keeping track of these
logs who is making them available who is
using that data I am aware of a couple
organizations who are taking public data
stores replicating them on their own
internal servers which is perfectly fine
I mean they're open data so that's
perfectly fine it's not a problem with
that but the reason that they're doing
that is so that no one is tracking their
behavior if you think about how many of
these data stores are run by government
institutions are the usage logs subject
to FOIA requests they may be so water
policies and practices regarding the
tracking of researcher behavior in these
systems and what are the policies that
those providers have to to manage that
that flow of information another issue i
think is relevant here is the
replication and the interaction with
other systems that is taking place when
accessing data
again this is sort of the the Adobe
Digital Editions issue are you sharing
these data over secure protocols even if
it is even if it does contain personally
identifiable information how secure is
that transmission process another
important information that another
important vector that I don't think we
spend enough time on is the metadata
that's associated with these data sets
what sort of information are we storing
and sharing related to provenance
minimum viable consent what sort of what
was the policy or the legal constraints
of the community where this data was
created Steven mentioned this in his
keynote yesterday I think there's many
issues here about the the international
legal aspects of data sharing and how do
we describe those and the many different
legal frameworks HIPAA and FERPA and EC
privacy laws etc this is a very complex
ecosystem in which we're operating and
the legal environment is incredibly
complex and often contradictory I you
know I think we we are all operating in
in this context and how do we navigate
some of this so those are some of the
issues that we are considering and what
do we do about these to be honest I'm
not exactly sure and that's why I'm
talking to you all but I think the
indisputable fact is the data analysis
data gathering data sharing can be an
extremely useful and powerful tool to
produce novel discoveries and we don't
want to be in a situation where we are
limited either by legislation limited by
patron involvement and engagement in
these systems so how do we support
discoveries how do we do support this
infrastructure
in a way that addresses some of these
privacy concerns one approach that it
nice o is undertaking presently related
specifically to publisher and publisher
library systems and software providers
in our community are looking at is an
initiative to develop some principles
around patron privacy in these systems I
want to shout out to the mellon
Foundation for generously funding this
work it was modest amount of funding but
I really appreciate their their support
of these issues and we've undertaken
about a six-month project which
culminated with an in-person event in
San Francisco back at the end of June
this is the mason center where we met
and spent two days discussing this the
goal of this project is to establish a
framework of principles that describe
how information systems should respect
the privacy of patron data and we are
working on a set of draft principles
that cover these this set of different
topics talking about transparency what's
what sort of policies and descriptions
and statements should be made by
organizations about their their
perspective on privacy issues around
security issues around data collection
and how it should be used the
responsibilities of the actors in the
community to do awareness you know it
doesn't help anyone if you have a
privacy policy that is buried on your
website so how proactive do you need to
be to describe to users I mean we don't
want to go quite so far as they say the
EU approach we're just about every time
I hit a page it's like Oh privacy
privacy privacy which just teaches
people to ignore it but other option you
know other issues are on informed
consent what does it mean to consent how
should data be shared in what way should
it be shared what sort of anonymous
ation issues are dealt with
tation issues around anonymous use so
can I use a system without displaying to
the community that I am Todd carpenter
and I've logged in at a particular time
as well as accountability sort of is
anyone actually following their
procedures I mean google has a privacy
policy has anyone ever audited it do we
know that Google is conformant with its
own policy practices so my issue is can
we do something here similar within the
research data community I think we can I
think we can engage the researcher
community the researchers administrators
the folks who run repositories the folks
who run tool create tools create
analytical Suites of services data
publishers funding organizations as well
as privacy advocates I think there is an
opportunity here for us to engage in a
conversation to define a consensus set
of principles that are specific to
research data and its use and I think
this is going to be really important
because we do want to foster the
continued development of this research
we do want to foster the development of
these tools and that all goes back to
the willingness of the human subjects
who are creating this data to actually
allow its creation allow its sharing and
also I like to think that we might be in
a position to avoid some of the kind of
more stringent legal constraints on our
industry which might result if we don't
if we aren't proactive in protecting
patrons protecting the privacy of the
subjects of the data were collecting so
I'm happy to take any questions included
here in the slide deck which i'll post a
SlideShare uh no
from also distributes it are a few links
to some of the nicer project on privacy
and some other some other resources so
happy to take any questions thank you